I'm excited for this next segment
because joining me in this moment are
the stars of duck family treasure season
two has just dropped exclusively on
foxnation.com and we have a little sneak
peek for you watch
growing up in Louisiana you learn how to
crawl then walk and then put out
crawfish traps well I'm treasure hunting
I'll be treasure hunting this is about
the easiest hunting that you can do
[Music]
with the greatest payoff there's a
reason Louisiana that's famous for
crawfish because you don't have to go
far as you'll find them
anything else better to eat on the
planet
joining me now is Jason Missy Robertson
stars of duck family treasure on Fox
Nation Jace this season takes you all
over the country searching for buried
treasure what are we going to learn in
the show well you're going to learn that
you know treasure comes in various forms
so we find relics we're looking for
silver and gold and all kind of old
things that are under the ground but we
also are you know we're looking for
supper and so uh you know the Crawfish
is way up on the list of treasures that
I prefer so uh then then there's our
family we do this together so that's
that's uh one of life's great Treasures
you know Missy you posted a picture
online of you out fishing and you got a
great catch and um tell me the story
behind it and when you catch fish do you
make the guys actually prep the fish and
cook dinner okay you're acting like
that's a thing that happens all the time
that does not happen just hearing you
say when you were out fishing they set
us up to succeed we'll say that but he
kind of dropped a bombshell on me so
you'll have to watch the episode to see
it but Jessica and I went out there and
actually brought the fish in which was a
feat in and of itself but no I don't
clean them I don't even cook them he
does it all yeah
cooker yeah that was the that's why that
show took off because we set them out
but then we got a lead to go find some
Buried Treasure and I was like babe take
care of this all you got to do what
could go wrong next thing you know
they're out there screaming well the
only reason I agreed to it is because
they taste so good they taste good
especially when you don't have to clean
up more cook them that's better yes all
right I want to go to a little more
serious topic because tonight in
California the LA Dodgers are
celebrating Pride night and as they
celebrate Pride night they're giving the
community hero award to the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence just here's a slice
of of what the sis the sisters represent
[Music]
all right
so I'm a Catholic we're all Christians
um there is I'm I'm absolutely so
offended by this group but that the
Dodgers would actually bring them in and
to mock Catholics and Christians as a
whole to mock the cross what is your
response to what the doctors are doing
here well it's real unfortunate and sad
we were actually Dodger fans when I was
a kid uh back in the Steve Garvey Ron
say you know Dusty Baker days and to see
that now I'm like because here we are as
Christians and I think misrepresented in
a lot of ways because we treat everyone
with love and respect Even in our
disagreements but to have that make fun
of us for no other reason than to just
make fun of us yeah and and for have us
to celebrate baseball and that kind of
decision and lifestyle that's asking too
much you know Missy I can't imagine what
would happen if Christians were mocking
you know those that were in the lgbtq
plus Community or mocking folks from
other religions America would go crazy
but here a Christians are a fair game
I I've never seen that clip before until
now and that actually gave me chills
that that right there is evil so and and
the Lord talks about that many times in
the Bible and so we will be persecuted
for standing up for what is right but as
Christians that's what we should do and
so many times when we do that we will be
blessed because of it and we need to
stand up not because that that is wrong
and evil and we need to be scared of
that but for our own children and for
the generations after us if they're
trying to normalize that that is okay
that is not okay our creator loves us
more than anything else on the planet he
loves those people we do too if they
knew Jesus the way we did they wouldn't
do that it would be mocking the cross no
just real quick we're coming up upon
Father's Day what does Father's Day mean
to the Robertson family and there's so
much push against families right now
demonizing families and demonizing men
calling them toxic what does it mean to
to your family well that means a lot I
mean you know the whole problem with our
society and with kids and what they're
thinking it starts in the home and uh
and fathers need to be present and you
know I wasn't raised in a good
environment my dad has written books
about it there's a movie coming out this
year in September about his life leading
up to him coming to the Lord but I got
to see his transformation and him turn
from being a terrible human being to a
great father and so it's inspiring he
passed it down to us so how about you
Missy I was going to say I'm bragging on
him because he is what you would call a
manly man but not just because of the
way he looks with a beard and knows how
to shoot a gun and and cook and clean
for his family but it's because he
stands up for our family he's making the
hard choices and the hard decisions even
on the plane he challenged me
spiritually to be a better mom and a
better sister in Christ to some of the
other people in my life and so that's
what a manly man does is leads his
family in the Lord and makes those hard
decisions and that's what we're going to
celebrate on Father's Day your leads he
provides he cares for and leads to Faith
that is it from my own personal
experience we had an issue in our family
we didn't know where we were going and
Rachel said the Robertsons will have the
answer and you guys were wonderful
helping out the Duffys and we are so
grateful for that and so grateful for
your testing all you do on the show so
Jason Missy thank you make sure to watch
the brand new season of Duck family
treasure it's right now on foxnation.com
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else